we're going in three two
whatever it takes
look at the world around you is it not
more peaceful
let's finish this Avengers and gay rated
pg-13 tickets how's it going everybody
it's Warren and there have been a ton of
Avengers and game trailers and TV spots
so many that it's pretty easy for some
to slip through the cracks but we have
to talk about this one because there is
a major reveal that we have not seen in
any of the other trailers and that is we
hear the Hulk speaking for the very
first time in this trailer if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe I'm
doing an Infinity Gauntlet and a famous
painting giveaway I'll talk more about
the giveaway at the end of the video so
this TV spot starts with the Avengers in
their white suits walk into what I
believe is the quantum tunnel this is
the part in the movie where they all go
back in time and we hear a voice saying
that we're going in three two one
now this voice is new but it's also very
familiar it kind of sounds like the Hulk
but it also kind of sounds like Banner
but instead of being one of them it's
actually both of them this is the first
time that we hear professor Hulk talk
there's a clear distinction between this
voice and banners voice and this voice
and the Hulk's voice and I like how they
made the voice out it does really sound
like it's both of them combined now they
have it fully revealed professor Hulk in
any of the TV spots but many people
believe that we have seen his arm when
all of the Avengers put their hands
together because there's an arm in there
that is way too big to be any normal arm
hearing professor Hulk's voice in this
trailer is the first true confirmation
that we are going to see him in Avengers
endgame it's been widely speculated for
a while and it's pretty much all but
confirmed but it's nice to get our first
tiny confirmation of it and then we get
new footage from Thanos that could
possibly be pretty revealing he's
talking to the Avengers and he says take
a look at the world around you is it not
more peaceful this could be proof that
Thanos does in fact go to earth which
would make sense because if he's talking
to the Avengers saying take a look at
the world around you as in take a look
at your world now he would be referring
to Earth there is a chance that they
could be on another planet but it is
most likely earth because if this was
typed into there wouldn't really be
anybody else there but that's it from
the short TV spot let me know what you
all think about this in the comments
down below and let me know what you all
think about Professor Hulk speaking and
if you haven't seen it yet I did a fan
os-- diss track Avengers end game parody
just for fun if you haven't seen it I'll
link it up above and of course if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
I'm giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark Thanos
painting by glow by boat and you can
also find some of his other work at
globe by boat comm I'll put the link in
the description down below all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]